hello everybody my name is Margaret [ __ ]
everybody my name is snippy did someone
speak wait stop do some veg did you plan
that no I don't think he did it
hello everybody my name is Margo and
welcome to drunk minecraft the
long-awaited return with Wade and Bob
say hi yeah yeah hey obviously we are
not drunk enough we had a little bit of
a drink before this at least one / Bob I
think cleared too and we're all gonna
take a commemorative shot because I
still have this uh cinnamon whiskey with
how much is in one shot a one shot
glasses suede actually technically 1.5
ounces paid okay two ounces is a home
shot at 1.5 is like a you're at a bar
shot but two ounces is normal a size of
her home well yeah there are rounds
glasses you just never supposed to fill
them up to the bike I fill it up one out
so I guess maybe I'll take two yeah do
that way well now it's glass it's like a
shot glass is it like a skinny one just
a little little thing mine's a skull my
mind's amore sinjar cuz i live in the
south I'm not kidding it's a mason jar
we're doing this yeah we are hey cheers
everyone this is the back the back the
return of drunk minecraft blues singers
oh man oh my god is no solution oh yeah
as is customary I'll explain I'm
drinking bourbon oh very good small
distillery bourbon from Columbus Ohio
whoo I'm drinking are you drinking Marc
I'm drinking cinnamon whiskey which is
what got me through the game five nights
at [ __ ] boys and it was very fun very
fun I enjoyed it very much so that it
does not live up to its title no I'm
drinking Yingling but I'm also taking
shots of a apple rum well actually three
years ago from now he keep complaining
about how his three years been open but
closed and you know but not sealed
yeah okay doesn't know what those words
mean I'm gonna take what he said from
before we started I'm gonna insert it
right here
yeah but wasn't uncapped for three years
which is the yes oh well why why didn't
you get that often all right
the week that makes even more sense that
you would put a cap on it I mean it was
covered it was open
what does that make the hell okay go
ahead on it but it was unsealed it was
capped it was covered but it was open
Oh sealed what a wash is open like like
no okay like God opened it three years
ago
oh yes but if it was closed but not
filled it auto gonna Shepherd open yes
please we'll bring the bottle okay they
don't even know how English he went no
no can help that's it that's my modern
day when oh wait I didn't know Wade was
still here yeah yeah no girl
sounded like a mixture of goofy and a
Walter White son dad
winrich mark don't kill me blog this is
Wade mark Jesse we got a kook
that's Jerry Seinfeld [ __ ] what am i
doing is it toilet bowl cleaner or is it
math I am the one who knocks oh I'm
getting my voices way or the other
what an idiot like what I need it right
Bob for three years like the literal
interpretation of open like lidless okay
whatever fall that's that's what open
means yeah that's the only thing that
open means exactly are we doing a shot
every time or we drinking another yeah
shot
yeah not no we don't no one wants to die
away because the original idea was every
time we die we take a drink and then I
said I'm taking shots so that would not
work cuz boy howdy should have seen the
practice rounds for this sumbitch yeah
oh boy at the top in like five minutes
we're gonna have to really stretch it
out mm one take it easy
oh yeah Wade we know you're so good at
games and whatnot yeah you're gonna go
first Wade and then we're gonna follow
you
all right what should I start now now
technically this is a race
if you add Bob gonna kill me no no we're
gonna be very fair about this because
it's a return back to the camaraderie
that brought us all to during minecraft
in the first place
fair why do I live all God mark it out
of me no turn it now I got no son of a
[ __ ] way it's a fire ball that's not oh
no it's all right well I get a small sip
of fireball oh my gosh after all those
shots I'm gonna take it easy on the sips
they're gonna be pretty reasonable sips
it's weird cuz like a sip of fire or
whatever the hell and [ __ ] it is
fireball everyone it was fireball even a
little sips a fireball you didn't oh
[ __ ] were you about to turn around and
Chrissa his way Oh
I said wait no one appreciates how
difficult this is mark you should look
up and show them how long this is yes
and how how little of a shot that any of
us actually has finishing this oh god I
have no idea this is started off bad and
we're just gonna get works as it goes on
no no no man Bob I don't think it me it
meanders if you take it easy on those
[ __ ] I don't think it me in yesterday
the oh wait businesses uh you did yeah
okay [ __ ] good job there
it's your bare hands straight man
coaster runner came back did you know
that I heard about that yeah I mean like
I hope it comes out back in a big way
but I only heard about it peripherally
from the game grooms because they well
they like know the guy oh god I didn't
do that
alright I finally made to the first
eyelid again let's not [ __ ] this up oh
god dammit I don't want to take so many
sip ID of this really cut first
logically died oh god I was just gonna
were the best lay into us being pretty
drunk and just not playing the game junk
I said drunk drunk you idiot last year
all right man I mean this is just
getting us warmed up for the next
episodes because everyone complained
that the first episode of the series
wasn't bad enough
well that's because when we sit down oh
no ma'am oh no why fingers why oh this
is beautiful
I'm by beautiful me I mean it's a
terrible decision oh no what'd you do
this is okay granted they can take a
little sips here I are you guys selling
the first checkpoint cuz I'm not there
yet I'm almost to the second chick I
made it to the second checkpoint look at
me wait how do I uh are you all right
there way did you die no I didn't die Oh
Bob too much booze oh I love spawning
just time to see you die I got to get
over city
oh yeah come on all so close
ah okay I'm at the first checkpoint what
see you step on it yes just step on it
should be good good job Bob I'm gonna
pause here for a little bit and why I
think you should have to drink for me
for doing that uh I'll do a shot for
that one really oh cool well you got the
1 ounce class anyway I did a shot and a
half though to make up for the wilds
clay Bob you almost made it to the main
island why didn't you jump on that I
always start the beginning oh of course
Oh worst okay Wade took that shot for me
that's why I didn't take a shot after I
died
oh no I just didn't know what
I couldn't hear you over the raucous
roaring of the weed
I just died twice really quickly and I
didn't even drink for the first time I
died [ __ ] goddamn it oh man that is the
POTUS number why why God why
I want someone after they just make a
compilation of all our cries to the
heavens when we're falling you could
just do a supercut of uh Oh God
oh I'm gonna be so drunk and we're only
like five minutes in yep I don't write
oh oh I forgot we had grappling hooks
that's right [ __ ] all right wait I think
you deserve that one I don't know why
but I just think you are you got you
know it's funny usually in this
situation we would all be trying to kill
each other to win not even necessary no
one's gonna win are you guys looking for
you don't be like that way don't be like
that
I should be a whole case of beer here
I'm gonna drink it all
oh I didn't break again damn it just get
them late I'm gonna start using this
grappling hook because this is a bunch
of [ __ ] god I'm in so much trouble
right now how do you saw that one I
didn't see it but I bet it was
burglarious oh thank you guys I can see
all the death yeah but I can't there's
certain points that are just really hard
zombie we're going to die we've already
drinking so much oh I hope not remember
kitties we're professionals
oh there goes Bob we're professionals
we've been drinking for a long time now
I told you wait wait that water goes
nowhere we've tried that II need a
zombie cheat at some point here cuz I'm
stuck in the same stupid jump and I
can't do it
oh just my father's was impossible yeah
I made it to the third checkpoint I did
that one jump I did it with a grappling
hook
oh nice a pretty scream that's bad haha
oh god where have we gone though
so wrong I'm almost out of drink already
maybe I should have a game that didn't
go downhill this quickly
Oh who's on the ladder possible okay all
right okay yeah
oh no laughing's [ __ ] here I keep
missing the the jump on the spacebar
jump on yeah oh no what Oh two drinks
right that's me oh I have drank my
entire drink of this one damn area no I
[ __ ] did it
oh my crapoly sucks all of our gravely
sucks my grapple doesn't work I swear
yeah the control is broken my dad works
at [ __ ] no no no dad works at [ __ ] end
oh he knows how these grapples work
Scott you guys have watched this drink
go down in about a matter of two minutes
it's so wet look we're only like ten
minutes into the episode but I swear
we're drunker than we begged God [ __ ]
God
it's possible well it's cuz you and I
start off with shots mark even 'we
didn't drink his open not open rum but i
drank a beer to start with but i didn't
have a shot that's true yeah cuz your
rum was open or not open who knows oh
yeah there's a space because you're like
right above the spawn it won't work
there I'm pretty sure it is broke my
finger really Oh No
it's so hard oh yes why how do I make
this jump am i stupid
look Oh hit it so hard
are you all right way do you need to go
to the hospital I'm a lamb buddy get off
no what did you really break your finger
no I don't think so oh well then why did
you say you broke your finger no come on
Leah loud here oh oh oh I was so close
sir damn it I got a drink oh it hurts so
bad to press the ha I already I already
poured myself another shot
I wasn't sipping small enough no offense
Oh stupid fence oh oh wait I made it I
just made the jump that vexed me I did
it oh my god I did it I'm okay everyone
stop everyone hold your horses stay
where you are let's just take a break
and talk know what in the water fail
we just gotta talk so that we can give
ourselves a break cuz this is this is
onslaught of death yeah it is no bomb so
I'm talking points it's been a while
since the last drunk by crap it has
what's the last thing oh the last thing
we did was the penis kingdom wars that's
growl yeah yeah it wasn't penis cannons
was it very phallic like that well they
ended up being kind of like a penis well
I mean if you think of a cannon it's got
the long shaft not a PC it's very penis
II like Oliver irelia miss very piously
you guys are just dying oh wait I saw
that jeez doing wood fell off I didn't
realise up be out of the ladder cuz I
suck so damn bad oh man oh did he
okay he didn't give that for me and look
where I am
oh god we just stopped two of God's dude
[ __ ] I didn't stop oh no oh my god
so is there anything you guys want to
talk about well this is all happening um
all the zombie did add a ladder for me I
just didn't see it before I spat all
over my keyboard oh I've got a drink
oh come on I just fell off with our
stating still kind of haha oh my god oh
my god tiny buddy monarch I points how
about that blood-borne you played that
yet I have not everyone wants me to play
blood-borne well I had a stream of it
because forget trying to edit that
garbage yeah everyone everyone tells me
that I should stream it and maybe I will
just for funds and shits and giggles but
for now I just ready I'm so not dying
the Dark Souls like it's made by a
zombie having a letter for me dr. Bob he
had a bunch of letters cuz I saw wait
wait you got the checkpoint you're good
okay good for you Bob make you to your
checkpoint I could do this I can do this
I can do this sure huh yay oh yay oh
yeah yeah he everyone clap for Baja Dara
Singh oh I'm kidding
UNK enlike a little dizzy I think I'm
drinking too bad I said yeah I said we
should just pause here wait do not hit
me please oh gosh I finally [ __ ] made
it to this one all I can do this series
of jobs probably looking a little above
up just to hold hold hold hold
I have no fear mark okay I have a
front-row seat to your failure we're
good I got this mark this is the most
industry we've been just awful
episode Oh God all right Wade you test
this next jump for me I don't know how
I'm gonna make you in it well just relax
for a minute yeah I'll be down here hey
there's a ladder on the left side rush
where are you guys where the hell are ya
turn around oh I see you yeah we're up
here I wish I could be up there what all
you gotta do is get up here zombie
poured him to the next thing ja I don't
need help
got it okay I might need help more come
alive how are you alive oh you're else
oh you're back in the beginning so it
doesn't
she's gonna kill yourself oh [ __ ] oh my
god
this is so bad it's so bad so whose idea
was I love see you guys just come
flailing past me I think that's why
they're part of this whole is Bonnaroo
no don't go up the ladder oh why did I
go down the ladder that was out in the
water oh I can't even use zombies cheats
to help me ever doing parkour again well
we don't have calves Fargo Sears we
don't know what we're doing Oh God
everyone is just gonna be in the
comments like I'm so glad this is back
you guys are [ __ ] stupid I mean in
the end that's exactly what they came
for for us my drink is gone that is how
fast we've gone through this garbage
wait I'm drinking a 32-ounce glass and
it's almost gone oh my god boys 32 ounce
glass of what of it was probably three
issue her patan died coke oh [ __ ] Jesus
yeah I poured a lot of bourbon in it all
day you dumb son of a food if you hear
the leg is in my speech that was not on
purpose suburban that aren't a lot of
bourbon I leave and go get another drink
no I think we'd have to take a break
just to be responsible I don't died
though all I have left is the shots well
just I've been taking sips of my shots
and taking sips of fireball yeah he's
not as fun everyone everyone watch I'm
so close to you I'm watching you got
kids being with this ah oh that's good
oh that's not good darling oh god oh god
oh you're so close oh yeah he'll he
likes it where's the check boy in the
house
yes I made it I only used to go
Oh God I don't even curse on it but I'm
so damn inebriated overdone how do I get
over to wear it you guys right side of
the house
how right my skis I'm on the right side
of the house uh oh uh how potent is
fireball or I mean cinnamon whiskey
it's 33% so it's not full forty but [ __ ]
okay I found it okay Baba lightweight so
um I'm a light wakes I know food in my
stomach and this is a full flip at 40
wait where are you guys are you guys at
the next checkpoint we're a drunk
Mountain
Bell where all the house hey Bob how's
it going
oh no I know I did the same thing mark
you're so brave for jump in there I
don't it's a shortcut
uh-oh
face is tingly Oh Yuri spot on top of
the house when yeah exactly so I make
the jump to that block on the left there
yeah you go over here oh no I don't go
Bob oh push me down Jimmy what's
happening to wait something is happening
yeah Wade are you all right over there
why don't you jump too
oh I see the most I've had to drink it
alone Oh a lot of skill there Bob who
gonna work on it I'm holding on fun
drinks it's it's to the point where I
showdown drink more oh yeah yeah some
are done I don't mark tae-young awesome
huh this is not good we're are you into
the second episode by goddamn wait give
me your best Jerry Seinfeld doing a
Batman impression you know would be you
want to use chicken
we are the Soup Nazi you're just mixing
Seinfeld Batman do Jerry Seinfeld be
with or nuts or knots
pictures Kramer's face wait would you
hurry up oh sorry
Oh buddy it's so orbiting oh yeah my
whole body's like like to God and not
that usually I'm Asian warm and for
books wow that's a [ __ ] how do you do
that oh we've been trying Bob we've been
Johnny har first time I've seen that 40
percent wrong mm-hmm
hey Mark how's it goin it's nodes what
you didn't even get close sprint campus
oh this is gonna be a short episode
isn't it
where are you like I don't know two
minutes whatever I don't oh come on I
was on the ladder and everything L know
about the start [ __ ] that now you have
to die oh my god I'm gonna make it gonna
make it okay
ah um how about puke I forgot to swallow
oh this is hard
it's legitimately big killers okay wait
do that [ __ ] okay Wade you know
have you watched Breaking Bad just drool
by myself what do you watch Breaking Bad
oh [ __ ] I know who do you know Walter
White son uh
no but Dad where's breakfast do that but
as Batman but dad oh my god hunger for
justice dead so mean oh no is weird just
fight with my parents they've heard dad
oh are you who you cheat good job Oh Oh
everyone everyone everyone what everyone
are you guys making what you die
oh [ __ ] mom you did it you're not eat
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can't make Sam jump
i redo introduced oh ha ha
I'll just get stand right here to watch
you guys look at it fart oh yeah bill
drinking when you die no god no look at
me and we find dying I shot you I was
taking a break I was dying too much hey
wait I'm still drinking
I shouldn't be Bob I can't really not on
my level so you don't have to come on
mark you can do it once I pass you you
look like some [ __ ] you go skill and the
power and the drive and the [ __ ] let's
see wait try this come here wait come up
for it Oh are you laughing at me
yes okay why would I not be laughing
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] alright
otherwise that's all you want to do I
give you two jumps turbocharged um ah
[ __ ] happened I hit I hit the lighter
and I was doing a ladder and I didn't
know didn't happen I love you guys we've
been Donal whoa waiting for getting to
that they don't they're already waited
just like slouched over in the corner
like I love you guys all just I wish we
could live together dude we good
ion Oh in the Bahamas and not the
Bahamas gets a society then gigabit
internet since it fog oh yeah Maya condo
and kiss me so we can have Google Fiber
hey apparently Cincinnati this is good
oh no I'm with Google fiber's cheaper
though isn't it in that the whole thing
I don't know how much like 75 bucks a
month or something for Internet and it's
levity a month right now for Internet
I gave so much for my horrible horrible
awful Time Warner [ __ ]
oh no ya bum [ __ ] Jew bum [ __ ] Jew
[ __ ] Badu boo oh my god zombies
yourself tits out again knees putting
ladders everywhere he feels sorry for oh
dang it Dale wow this is much easier
with ladders everywhere I made it to the
next checkpoint guys he's uh oh [ __ ] me
hey the blocks are disappearing they're
just turning in a floating fence post
haha alright oh [ __ ] god damn it
have you been on my camera for like ten
minutes
I am like a lackey
turning away into this bottle rub after
you the beers and you weren't supposed
to take a shot every time you die you're
just play it's only a third of your
shots it's only half an ounce each time
that's a big ass shift I'm taking like a
tidy
that's right lot about that's a lot
prettier I'm cross-eyed she's good like
20 she's been 30 minutes
oh no no we were biessing for the first
place 20 minutes into the first episodes
and I'm a private chord like three we're
gonna die I think we're gonna take it
slower after this one because frankly
like what we've done now will last
anyone even close to the end mark how
far you I don't what what is that what
it's about right next to you how could I
be close oh god I don't even know what
what this is supposed to be like this is
some [ __ ] here holy crap oh I did it
oh my god it's [ __ ] ha ha ha [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] moan moan moan Oh turns out
it's not that hard
oh whatever I did it you didn't [ __ ] I'm
sure as soon as I get there it's gonna
be walk
oh so hard mob is so hard
oh I start to record a video for
tomorrow
why I'm like the easiest things right
now I'm having trouble I'm recording for
five nights at [ __ ] boys tonight to the
second one no you haven't finished the
second one oh I just I just didn't
ashish wait why by the starting island
ha ha you probably fell off we'd just
kill yourself did i okay wait does that
count as a second death no no stick a
shot for it so I'm good
why are you taking full shot I thought
it's just that episode it's just gonna
be me and mark oh ouch doesn't have a
night oh my darling do Sean Connery and
Batman on the starting I lose son of a
[ __ ] you're kidding
shake it knocks dad bye bye Batman so
she'll so hard
Oh martini
Marty how the drugs calling that's
Wilfred Wharf - [ __ ]
sup Dom be help I fell backwards a
checkpoint rookie spawn on the second
checkpoint why did you press the second
checkpoint okay we really did so this is
like a what not to do when you play this
kind of episode okay all right here's
the deal we got like two minutes left
whoever's farthest after two minutes
when I stopped Rick I just died on the
first job dude stop geez if I didn't
know you would handle your booze like I
do worried I've seen you'd respond in
the second sector from 31 birthday a few
years ago I learned I have a pretty good
amount that I can live through wait
who's who's not there was that foster
Jesse here Oh mr. Jesse ha ha
Arg mark thank you
oh oh yeah yeah sure why did I run I
depress the Run button boom huh I'm
gonna get this who else can we do
impressions of I just Christopher Walken
Batman Oh No why let her why oh hey guys
I mean ha ha ha
you know what that is yeah Wow
hahahahaha she'll bad manner but do
Smeagol Batman what are you to try it
then I'll do it last okay
oh [ __ ] hey drugs going man precious
that's my space
alright Bobby your turn Smeagol back uh
uh uh uh
I see Smeagol smooth Oh smooth flow ah
why are the other drugs good there you
go oh hey I got transported up to I soon
the third checkpoint where are those uh
soda bottles hey I could do a little
Smeagol when I'm drunk I can't
applesauce cool I can't do talky
mushroom my vocalize doesn't what is
this fence post [ __ ] that's what I
say that's nice soon when I got to the
fence post [ __ ] I did it
hey wait come get me [ __ ] haha I made it
Smith fair so no like turn my pickaxe
into the abyss Oh fair I'm in it I'm on
the pull of Bob look at me now how you
like me no wait you know what
how did you okay I think that does it
I'm in the pit of death
so who's ahead of who Bob Boyd oh no
ladders I just fell so I'm winning Oh
Bob wins wait my wins winner
yes Bob's prize he gets to save the
outro oh okay what's your outro I don't
know
thanks for watching guys and see you in
the next video that's the game feel sigh
hey guy wait no I want it I forgot I
wanted to say like more at the end there
let's say it I forgot just say it I
can't remember cuz I was gonna like cuz
it's like this first it's like the first
thing back ok uh do it oh it was I'm in
sailing thank you guys for joining us we
like this is the one of the longest
running series we've ever had and it's a
pleasure to play with my good friends
Bob and wait and just have the most fun
more fun than anybody should have when
they're playing minecraft I did the jump
who offer but yeah just thank you guys
so much we hope you enjoyed this trip
back to drunk minecraft we want to do
this more often
and we're gonna record more just thank
you guys for the constant support and
everyone the community that loves this
series cuz she's a stupid fun hey that's
all I want to say hey you you one guys
say uh don't drink like we did today
and don't do it yeah remember that we're
drinking responsibly
like don't croak don't try to do
whatever the hell we're doing to real
life don't this at home even though
we're do it alright thanks again
everybody check out the other drunk
minecraft DEFA so this is like 69 of
them or something late to the annotation
Wow here here here on Bob and Wade's
face alt Suns antigen thanks get
everybody as always we'll see you in the
next one
check out Vox Populi good for you right
that's what I was gonna say Vox Populi
it's the server that we play on there's
a link in the description oh my god
zombie mole he's like the best zombie
here he's listening he felt a bit he's
on the server Jesus I drank a lot is
horrible this was ot oh [ __ ]
thanks again bye guy getting something
yep got make Godzilla destroy everything
and you're worried about the kind of
shoes
the end of the episode is Jesus I drank
a lot of this fire [ __ ] hi
I just noticed like when I was done with
five bags of [ __ ] boys it with three
core it was like only a quarter gone
it's down to half I put so much shots of
the wrong guy I'd [ __ ] up would not be
was any of that even comprehensible
it was super hilarious Oh like